[Música]
vocês sabiam que no brasil existe 45
milhões e 600 mil pessoas com
deficiência seja ela visual auditiva
motora eo a intelectual 24% da população
brasileira que apesar de ter todas as
leis que amparam que lhes dão os
direitos não vive em uma sociedade
inclusiva
ainda existe muito oita muito medo muito
preconceito que não possibilita que elas
têm uma vida com qualidade
estou falando de brasil não só de imóvel
de modo ontem 22 mil 280 pessoas com
deficiência ou seja 27 e meio por cento
esses dados são do ibge é de 2010
onde estão essas pessoas porque são
invisíveis porque nós vimos por aí
elas estão totalmente à margem da
sociedade e eles precisam exercer o seu
protagonismo
há sempre necessidade assim como nós
apenas tem uma deficiência
mas são pessoas perfeitas em todos os
sentidos
agora eu pergunto onde estão essas
pessoas a quente móvel e o que ela
significariam para a economia o que ela
se podem significar para a sociedade e
para a educação o que elas podem
significar para cada um de vocês eu sei
que se alguém é que tiver uma pessoa com
deficiência
a divisão nessa pessoa vai ser
diferenciada mas se não tiver não é
problema de pele
às vezes essa necessidade passa a falar
dos outros
nesses 27 um quarto da população
brasileira
apenas cheguei aqui apenas 7% conseguiu
completar o ensino superior
o ensino médio completo 18% fundamental
mas 61% mim ter acesso às escolas ou não
concluiu o ensino fundamental
e esta situação recai direto no mercado
de trabalho sem a mão de obra
qualificada como eles vão conseguir e e
dos 30 milhões de pessoas com
deficiência em idade de trabalhar um
pouco mais de 1% têm carteira assinada
é preciso a gente problematizar que a
situação é de um quarto de 1 4% da
população brasileira da população de
potência
agora vocês podem perguntar porque é que
eu milito mais na causa da inclusão
eu sou pedagoga e trabalha como diretora
a professora capacitadora vez ensino
infantil até a universidade
trabalhei com todos os tipos de
deficiência e tive o prazer foi
convidada para trabalhar na fae e 91 a
86 na recém-criada pai da vítima hoje
uma referência não sabia o que deus
estava me preparando para um presente
muito grande que eu ganharei 9999 nasceu
a minha neta alice um cegueira total
e eu que tinha acabado de me aposentar
com 30 anos na educação como
pesquisadora praticando demais
eu não me vi bruta teve totalmente ao
léu para tratar de uma pessoa com
deficiência assim então parti pra
estudar investigar pra aprender nessa
época tinha inclusive a oportunidade de
participar de um programa do ministério
da educação educar para a diversidade
onde nós trabalhamos no leste mineiro
todinho fazendo capacitações e todos os
pólos
eis uma oportunidade para conhecer
praticamente todas as histórias todas as
é escolas do oeste mineiro todas as
secretarias
eu tive positiva a condição maior ainda
de estar juntos com os mentores da
educação especial foi quando orientou
mais a partir de 2005
então tive contato com essas pessoas ea
partir daí eu fui aprendendo fui vindo a
realidade da sala de recurso a realidade
das prefeituras em relação à educação do
ensino especial a luta para conseguir
alguma coisa e vi também o as leis
chegando então eu participei de todo
tudo isso eu vivenciei mas paralelo a
esse estudo
vamos inserir alice escolhem escola
a primeira escola rejeitou diretamente
não posso receber
eu não sei trabalhar com uma pessoa cega
só que quem sabe né gente tinha que
aprender isso ele foi primeiro segue a
procurar na escola
a segunda escola aceitou a 20 mais de
braços abertos mesmo primeiro mesmo
segundo período
a professora me chama socialismo não vai
ser todo mundo desse ano porque ela não
vai aprender a ler
eu falei puxa como você vai aprender com
que são realmente as dificuldades o que
você tem que vencer com as pontas dos
dedos faleiro braille a terceira escola
foi feita a inclusão de áreas isoladas
segundo período até oitavas e nas idéias
em primeiro nas séries iniciais
foi uma inclusão total perfeito
interagir com os colegas aprendendo com
adaptação curricular e tudo mais mas a
partir das séries finais
a coisa não aconteceu porque era 19
professores somente um ou dois faziam de
vez em quando até então ela começou a
esquecer tudo o que ela tinha aprendido
nós lembramos no 9º ano para uma escola
pública pela escola pública já existia
esse amparo legal do professor de apoio
e se ampara em relação a essas
tecnologias da capacitação
quando chegamos
cego não têm direito a professora de
apoio à lei não permite professor de
apoio permite para surdo para autista
para determinados casos de deficiência
intelectual mas o sérvio não precisa
sendo que isso estava claramente nas
entrelinhas da lei
só que ninguém tenha buscado direito mas
nós buscamos e conseguimos o professor
de apoio o direito do professor de apoio
para alice que agora está sendo dado
para todos os cegos e baixa eles não
estão vindo aqui dentro depois dela
conseguimos o direito mas não
conseguimos o profissional não
encontramos um profissional qualificado
para trabalhar com as necessidades
educacionais de uma pessoa com
deficiência assim e é este professor
ele precisa essas ações inclusivas a
escola é são de total importância porque
se você não adaptar às necessidades dos
cegos
você não está equiparando as
oportunidades a oportunidade e com isso
têm dificuldade para aprender porque um
cérebro principalmente várias
deficiências precisam do concreto pegar
pra prender os olhos estão aqui e aqui
os dedos a ponta dos dedos dos ouvidos
se não lhe foi oferecida se não lhes é
oferecido essa oportunidade não acontece
aprendizagem e principalmente os jovens
nessa idade escolar
eles têm uma necessidade imensa de
inserção os seus pares de necessidade de
é conviver de socialização e tudo mais
resultado alice não conseguiu completar
o terceiro ano do ensino médio e hoje
ela
nós procuramos ainda alguma alternativa
para que ela tenha vontade de se casar e
essa realidade de alício é a realidade
da maioria das pessoas com deficiência
que procura se você tem o exemplo dela
mas olha aqui ainda hoje
vejam existe a rampa de acesso existe o
piso tátil
o irã está impossibilitada de transitar
por que datena acessibilidade está a
sensibilidade daqui acessibilidade
física que tony está aqui porque ela não
consegue trazer essa sensibilidade ela
falta muito
quando você não consegue comunicar com a
pessoa e dentro do seu código 71 que o
braga é o fibra sobre uma comunicação
alternativa
quando nós não conseguimos oferecer os
instrumentos e as estratégias
necessárias para tanto a aprendizagem
quanto a lazer quanto do trabalho a
gente não faz essa declaração quando nós
não cumprimos as políticas públicas
públicas que estão ali se ela gosta de
tocar as pessoas e ver se é bonito ou
não e é normalmente é certa ela certa
porque ela tem um sentimento ela capta
aquela aquela que gere aquela energia
que a pessoa está passando
ela disse que enxerga com os olhos do
coração
agora eu pergunto vocês nós sim uma
deficiência aparente
não que nós entenderíamos neste mundo
sem acessibilidade total
o problema está em nós e não damos a
esses direitos estão preconizados na lei
que são próprios da ética pessoal de um
coração aberto nós que não damos esse
direito às pessoas com deficiência
porque nós não temos nós não promovemos
a acessibilidade atitudinal nossas
atitudes contradizem as necessidades
porque as leis e os direitos e som
o desafio então que a gente se encontra
é como promover esta sociedade essa
escola inclusiva e vai trabalhar de
acordo com as diferenças individuais
aqui não há necessidade nem de especial
em deficiência mas quantas difícil pois
as necessidades individuais escola que a
comunidade que a sociedade tem que
prover então nós temos primeiro que
acabar com a população à discriminação e
à exclusão e daí surgiu a idéia do
trailer que é o centro de referência em
educação inclusiva ativo procurada por
um prefeito da época
ele me pediu que criasse uma escola para
crianças do tipo da alice era muito bem
porém não mas o caminho é esse
então eu fui dos grandes centros é para
trabalho com cegos e surdos em belo
horizonte rio de janeiro são paulo e
trouxe agregado aquelas aquela realidade
que eu vi no em todo leste mineiro
nós elaboramos estruturamos uma idéia
para construir o centro ideal aqui moço
e foi isso que aconteceu
nós começamos em 2 de janeiro fevereiro
de 2008
eu tive a oportunidade de pela
secretaria de educação selecionar os
melhores professores da rede que
quisessem aceitar o desafio de trabalhar
com crianças com deficiências de
aprendizagem crianças cegas surdas e com
baixa visão e nós começamos em fevereiro
de 2008 o 340 alunos e com cinco
profissionais lembrando que o crea
nasceu nós já tínhamos na prefeitura o
projeto ame e trabalhava com crianças
com dificuldades de aprendizagem e é um
pouquinho diferente
esses professores que foram convidados
ele se dedicar totalmente à causa eles
se tornaram perfeito os profissionais da
inclusão eles aprofundaram seus estudos
e sua prática dentro da sua
especialidade e hoje são verdadeiros
multiplicadores tanto do seu
conhecimento quanto dessa experiência
ímpar da epa com essas crianças
elano 36 nós oferecemos atendimento
pedagógico terapêutico iludir
e nós conseguimos provar que a partir do
momento que o sistema inclusivo funciona
na sociedade é possível tudo é possível
um trabalho maravilhoso é possível você
dar a essas pessoas uma qualidade de
vida uma aprendizagem real uma
aprendizagem duradoura e alegria deles e
vamos ver como eles dizem
a alegria a vontade de ver e autoestima
resgatamos com a maior facilidade porque
eles convivem num ambiente que não têm
nada que lhe impeça não têm carreira
daquele ambiente porque é possível fazer
isso gente porque a legislação inclusive
já existe as políticas públicas estão aí
completas
nós precisamos de que uma gestão
inclusiva de verdade seja ela política é
precisa ser política e educacional
nós precisamos de professores e
realmente dominem arte de trabalhar com
as pessoas com deficiência que queiram
estudar cada dia mais porque os estudos
não acabo sempre tem uma novidade a
gente tem que estar sempre aperfeiçoando
que o atendimento educacional
especializado que exista na escola ele
funciona realmente tem trabalho de
acordo com os objetivos não seja uma
simples sala naquela escola
nós precisamos de uma família atuante
porque a família e que vai estar fazendo
essa ponte dos seus conhecimentos o seu
conhecimento da pessoa uma escola com a
sociedade então a família está sempre do
nosso lado
precisamos de uma comunidade escolar
participativa
porque a pessoa com deficiência ela não
é de responsabilidade do professor de
apoio ou do professor da sala de aula
além de responsabilidade de toda a
escola
todos têm que abraçar essa causa e como
a rede de apoio e graças a deus a gente
sempre conseguiu parceiros dentro da
prefeitura parceiros da sociedade
nós conseguimos realmente uma sociedade
inclusiva uma sociedade que vai estar
preparada para tratar com igualdade
todas as pessoas independente da sua
defesa
eu não e se não tiver adequado vamos
partir para outras leis que vão
possibilitar este processo acontecimento
deste francês
o que a gente ouve é justamente isso que
eu falei resgate de vida resgate de
autoestima resgate de reconhecimento das
potencialidades da pessoa e incluem
várias demonstrações coral shows
atletismo
conseguimos levar duas pessoas ao hut
nacional
então é muita realização porque a gente
o que fica na gente
se nós não reconhecemos realmente se não
nos conscientizarmos realmente dessa
situação nós não vamos ver as
possibilidades
as potencialidades a riqueza que é cada
pessoa com deficiência e aqui eu trago
para vocês dois casos a que se ana nos
procurou ao entrar no ensino médio
porque ela não sabia nada de exatos e
ela queria passar no vestibular
essa menina ela se encontrou no creia
principalmente na concretização e na
música ela que nunca tinha feito aula de
educação física na sua casa dá nunca
tive nas escolas
ela ganhou medalha de ouro em arremesso
de peso e ela aprendeu a aprender
ela conquistou aqui ela conquistou o
diploma dela de psicólogas e hoje ela
está terminando o mestrado na faculdade
de são carlos em são paulo
então é um exemplo que a gente mostra
que quando você tem o apoio quando você
tem tudo aí a coisa acontece
o caso das áreas que chegou não creia
precisando aprender tudo em relação à
cegueira
ela foi a colocada no ranking é
classificada projeto nacional e hoje ele
está feliz porque casou com o aluno cego
do treino também constituiu a sua
família está feliz hoje com a sua filha
então gente nós temos necessidade
de putin no ar identificar esses
desafios vencer esses desafios e remover
essas barreiras
temos que dar resposta adequada esses
desafios entender o significado real de
inclusão inteira inclusão como filosofia
de vida
a partir daí nós vamos ter esta
sociedade inclusiva presente preservando
o valor da igualdade
nós vamos construir uma nova sociedade
então eu convido vocês pra nos ajudar a
reinventar esse futuro para as pessoas
com deficiência abrir o horizonte de
possibilidades para que ela seja
realmente protagonistas de sua vez o
convite está feito está feito
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]